I'm Jake Foley
I'm 57.
I'm again
life's just a game right
it's all in how you read and respond to
your opponents
Sam tell you what's going on only that
is big Stakes
there needs to be a catalyst
and I don't have time to wait around for
these guys to tell me the truth
cheese let's
25 million on the table who are these
guys it's coconut and I want to play
forgive my cynicism but wants to catch
but I just thought without the stakes
tonight
Rose 175.
follow him Jake goes all in
I'm not surprised Alex
I poisoned you no that's not funny
I did ask a lot of questions I never got
any satisfactory answers I'm all right
with death I'm not I can't die
this is another one of your surprises
Jake I don't know where we are let's go
okay we got the guys nobody's home check
around they're hiding somewhere
know you're still here Jake
Dad what's she doing here hello there's
six of us and three of them we can take
them
life's just a game right now
maximize your voice
minimize your losses
and stay in the game as long as you can
[Music]